get your occupation on y'all it's time
for protests and violence okay folks
we've all been reading about the whole
Occupy movement so I decided to go down
to occupy Dallas and interview a few
folks
unfortunately the occupiers were on
lunch break but I did manage to catch
some self professed libertarians
protesting the Fed ending the Federal
Reserve I'm on board with that so I
thought that I'd be in good company
until they're coming at us from so many
different directions right with the food
the water the vaccinations in Iran and
we those only things in one sense if we
hold on what you mean by that the
additives are putting on food the
nutrients that they don't have in
trembled
but you've been out of the United States
government is systematically suppressing
an information area or member you know
they don't realize to the people up
above they're very very late
sinister there are no evil
it should be noted that every single one
of them was a 9/11 truther and believed
that the government is trying to kill us
through our water supply and give us
cancer but they did say that them and
the whole Occupy movement were part of
the same giant revolution so let's
examine the key points of this whole
Occupy movement now so do I anybody who
watches this channel knows that I was
completely against the bank bailouts and
hate crony capitalism more than anybody
now these people mainly hate big banks
because of their giant political
contributions so I think they're
protesting Barack Obama so on this we
agree but the place where they lose me
is when they believe that the solution
to corrupt government business
relationships is to increase taxes and
the size of government now you've all
heard this whole 99 percent number which
I think comes from the misconstrued idea
that 1% of the country owns 99 percent
of the wealth when the truth is that 47
percent of Americans don't even pay
taxes quick question if you're making no
money and paying no taxes how many
people can you employ but we hear folks
saying that some people are making so
much money that it's unfair okay let's
go with that Ben and Jerry are as
liberal as too lovable furry ice cream
Kings could possibly be and they
believed just that in the 1980s they say
that the highest paid employee at their
company should never make more than five
times that of the lowest paid employee
surprisingly enough their company was in
the red and they needed to hire a new
CEO did they come into the real world
and scrap that whole salary cap can you
still enjoy a pint of chunky monkey
says the movement trying to gain steam
through a Twitter hashtag listen I hate
crony capitalism more than anybody
especially the Wall Street and bank
bailouts but if you want to talk about
politicians being corrupted why aren't
we talking unions now I've used this
list many times in this channel where
we've shown people the list of top
political donors from 1989 to 2010 so
why aren't these occupiers protesting
things like the UAW the teachers unions
or even places like Solyndra oh of
course
maybe it's because the unions are
supporting this movement through both
money and manpower that couldn't be
because they want to throw Americans off
the scent of the real string pullers
could it I don't know I don't know I can
guess they hate capitalism but they love
weed and despite what the media has
tried to sell us these protests are
pathetically attended with numbers of
people that would be abysmal for any tea
party rally
maybe that's why members of this
movement are getting arrested in nearly
every major city across the country
they're just bored now I know this
movement might be cute and entertaining
for a bit but just remember folks if
you're part of the 53% of Americans who
pay taxes and those people want what you
have eventually they're going to have to
try and take it by force ultimately
whose party won't go without violent
wind revolution we have the revolution
revolution that is helpful by watching
us don't the revolution
socialism yeah go ahead and give it your
best shot mr. Luis Guzman look-alike or
easy to find